et pour le président ukrainien la doite
insisté sur la nécessité de
démilitariser cette zone écouter
la démilitarisation du territoire de la
centrale est l'objectif de tous les
efforts eux craignent un et
internationaux il est regrettable que
nous n'ayons pas encore entendu les
messages que nous voulions entendre de
la part de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique nous en avions parlé
avec son président monsieur grossi lors
de notre rencontre à kiev c'était le
point essentiel de nos discussions notre
objectif est clair la démilitarisation
et le contrôle totale par nos
travailleurs du nucléaire